a week ago Sony asked if one of us from
the Australian office would like to come
along and try and be nice and Drake for
a day now for absolutely no good reason
the opportunity was passed along to me
far and away the most unfit on
adventurous and unlikely to survive a
day as Nathan Drake of the frailer I
workout approximately once a year and
that's usually after a guilt inspired
New Year's resolution that I inevitably
flake out on every January
the only things Nathan Drake and I have
in common is that we're both sarcastic
smart asses with a penchant for combat
boots a trait that I'll admit really
does help when your lungs are burning
after hiking through the forest exit
this is an exercise but I'm getting
ahead of myself so how hard is it to be
a wolf scaling death-defying treasure
hunter for a day well pretty bloody hard
as it happens frequently in uncharted 4
you'll catch Nathan Drake saying he's
having a pretty great time he remarks on
the sweet views and the fun he's having
and that was certainly the mood that
kicked off the day as we soared over the
coast of Sydney in a helicopter of
course that was the first time in my
life for me and just like a Tuesday for
Nathan Drake is certainly your
run-of-the-mill Indiana Jones Han Solo
action man he even bears similarities to
other characters that aren't played by
Harrison Ford he can hang on walls by
his fingertips for days race down busy
streets in a four-wheel-drive killing
minimal civilians and survive falling a
lot seriously if you thought Lara Croft
fell a lot in term raider you'll want to
tally up how regularly gravity fails
Nate in uncharted so off I went to the
wilderness to try and survive a day as
Nathan Drake might I built a fairly
successful fire on my second trike did
my best not to pull an 8 and crash into
a rock ball while abseiling and squeeze
through rock formations that I'm pretty
sure were not up to code these bridges
are clearly not built to code sure they
are the pirate code
hahaha I even ate a worm yeah I don't
remember when they does that either but
I did it so I guess that's 1.4 jest and
like 804 Nate
of course for me it was safety first so
excuse the harness and helmet like
almost this stuff was harder than it
looked
comparatively Nate does stuff like this
and this and this all of which I think
Sony preferred us to avoid given the
enormous medical bills we would have
sent them fortunately at the end of all
that hiking was our trust to quadbikes
which are criminally fun and I felt just
like Nathan Drake well kind of alright
so I didn't get shot at or almost died
at any point during the day but I did
have a damn good time that said if you
do want to step it up to the adventuring
extremes of Nate probably best to do it
in game I think be sure to check out our
extensive uncharted 4 content on
GameSpot including my three story recap
videos although I didn't get bitten by a
dozen leeches making those so you
probably chose them well here
you